oh well and they need to talk about
Germany's of computations we score Ben
in the second side okay thanks so much
and so unless they talking mainly about
them that is create problems with
permutations
and basically this area of study started
with basil and frankel and 1977 and they
were interested in unlocks of the early
prorate out there and for permutations
so as you probably all know and the OS
Corellia theorem says that if we have a
family of subsets of 1 up to n and where
all the sets of size k and it's
intersecting meaning meaning there any
tea sets in the family have non-empty
interception and then its maximum
possible size is n minus 1 choose K
minus 1 and the number of such
containing the element 1 and and that
equality holds only if the the air
family is centered meaning this so that
this it consists of all subtypes contain
some fish diamonds so let me just write
that down since the arrows coed Ethan
from 50s and
doesn't if a the family of Kalin and
subsets of 1 up to n and it's
intercepting
and if K is and most over T so as the
values of most and minus 1 choose came
on this one and if K is strictly last
night over to the other quality and only
if a is all sets contain some and I
ok so
so these are Frank will work and
interested in this kind of question for
permutations they originally motivated
by the study of permutation codes and so
an intersecting family of permutations
means exactly what you think it means it
means that any T permutations and the
family agree on some point so so let me
just write that down so if a is a family
of permutations and I then you say that
a is intercepting if for any teeth
permutations and the family at some
point at which they agree ok and so the
basic question that based on Frankel
asks is then what's the maximum size and
intersecting family of permutations
and the answer is well it's best to take
a single point and take a look plant all
permutations fits and not point and then
they create this phase intersecting then
I house size at most n minus 1 factorial
a number of permutations mapping I to
our effort for anyway and and the proof
was a very sort of nice director
partitioning argument and he just um
take a cyclic permutation of order n and
I'm cycle and take the subgroup
generated by the insightful and he just
observed that this this subgroup is
shortly one transitive and any cheaper
mutations and it disagree everywhere and
the same is true for any luck cosets
that's all good also so any left coset
of this so cute prices form transitive
property any cheap annotations and
disagree everywhere and and that means
that any in cycling family contains at
most one element of this and this black
racer love cosets partition SN there
minus one factor other than their for a
maximum size of our inserts and family
must be n minus 1 factorial and let me
just write down quickly
let's consider the subgroup h which is a
socket generated by a nun circle Ron
Paul and if we write permutations in the
cycle now it's very in the sequence
notation then an answer I could and what
is this this is simply a nun cycle and
then the socket generated by it others
like this
and you can see that it's certain a
Latin square and ankeet permutations and
it disagree everywhere and the same is
true for any left coset or lit two pi h
as a proxy that's facing permutations
seven ones in the tea for a sim 1 is not
equal sigma TI surveys in sight single
it contains the most 10 min to h down
the page for any play and say something
over all black assets we have that the
size of a SAT most n minus 1 factorial
and so
as I said equality holds and in the
serum only if a is the form all
permutations mapping itj force on fixed
I and J and so only if the lethani a is
a co-starter the stabilizer of a point
this is that this turned out though to
be quite a lot harder to prove than is
usually the case with such terms and
doesn't Frankel actually couldn't prove
this and well they conjunction it and it
was perfectly by Cameron and key in 2003
and and different booths were were then
given by various other authors
so let me just write that down quickly
so call the old zone the FA and here's
what we call a one co set just means the
case I to the stabilizer a point I
correctional presentations with mapping
hi TJ some fixed or NJ and
and that's it therm of Cameron and key
and also slightly independently and
slightly later by Louise and Marvin easy
so along supriya this and coming and key
used a sort of compression operation and
or their to me to be precise affixing
operation which M which makes fun these
look more like Santa fun this but their
previous quite intricate and and later
on I'll mention a larger prey proof
which is an in sometimes cleaner and
more natural and but but now I'm going
to mention it the audio were the obvious
generalization of the data Frankel
through which doesn't Frankel
conjectures and and this is what happens
when the family of permutations is Tian
slicing and fixed T
so so if we have a finding of
plantations we say that it's tea and sex
anal if for any cheaper mutations in the
family there are two different points
where they agree I want Y t stencil
switch their am super very one azamara j
equals and oj early j & tea and and so
days i'm frank will conjectured that the
biggest ten starts in family and our son
is given by fixing t points and taking
all permutations fixing those two points
point wise so let me just write that
down
that conjecture that if a is T
intersecting then house size at most n
minus T factorial and provided and the
sufficiently large depending on T
and they also conjectured the cross he
holds and if a is what we call a Tico
set of SN and that just means them Kota
echoes that of a stabilizer of T points
so this contextual is proved in 2008 and
independently by me and and also by an
advocate and her I'm pulpo and and we
used pretty much share the same proof
schatje and and we after you a joint
paper and it's the strategy of the proof
is algebraic and so we use an eigenvalue
methods and but we also and make quite a
lot of nice of the representation theory
of our sin and in order to analyze the
eigen value so to speak and say now I'm
going to say a bit about the proof and
one wonders of the like tool we can to
take the g ya book which is salty to
install 7-foot website yeah so I should
have mentioned that I sir that's good
point and so so yeah day John Franco
actually observed that and though that
you can you can prove this conjecture
when T equals two and whenever an is a
prime power and also an T equals three
when n is one more than the prime power
and you know because fit for these
values of n there are shortly to
transitive sockets of a sign and shortly
to transfer sagas of us on and but there
aren't any shortly t chance of Socrates
of us on foot for any larger values of T
except trivial ones and a month one and
and and and so this this pitch off GM
well it is is certainly it certainly
can't work with subgroup so glutes now
now it's not possible that it might work
with subsets frontiers lodge but we know
that when t is 2 and foremost values of
n there aren't shortly chance of two
subsets either and and they're certainly
on transitive subgroups so and so yeah a
single question that that's that's in
many ways the first pitch strategy that
11 were Troy and I'm confronted with
this conjectured that and yeah but it
turns out unfortunately not to work
except for a few small values of N and
then fatigue alternate equals three
and
alright show you on
you're saying the very fixed T and
there's a shortly t chance of soap
creative as I said one months ago 1
times yeah and I didn't I'm not sure
about actually him he may well be right
there and I have to think about it and
I'm not familiar exactly what the
existence results after almost t trance
tips of groups and did you know what
they are as I feel better only 38 but
the air their selves in a smaller
because no one it's a good nice and
heated elderly they'll know we're
looking for a thoughtful time looking
for something that's almost like elected
he was independent permutation
yeah and I would definitely be rushed
he's looking out here and but but I
after stuffy and also this is quite a
bit different to this say and so the
basic and the basic two eigen value
result for for proving extreme results
as hoffman's theorem and so so this is
quite an old but basically it it it
gives you a bound for the maximum
possible sighting and the planet such an
irregular off and in terms of the
minimum eigen value if its adjacency
matrix so here this hoffman's the angle
so sniff em if g is number sex do your
girl
here's Jason C matrix I was liking by
these minimum eigen value lambda n burn
them he first as an independent set ng
that just means that then there's no
edge of the graph in the success and the
size of us isn't most once mill and
eigen value either d minus sin wagon
body x number of vertices of the graph
okay and say so say and so this gives it
a simple way of downing in the planets
number of a graph by solving a national
problem and if one can calculate the
minimum eigen value of the adjacency
matrix if you'll go up so and this
actually surprised it another way of
proving the days of phone call theorem
for T equals one and because in a second
family is precisely an independent sets
in the graph where you join any T
permutations if I mini if they disagree
everywhere so I'm if I let go of one and
the so-called arrangement graph one I
seven
meaning that its first access is
ascendant sub-steps it's just the
questionable pairs of connotations which
disagree everywhere burn em well as a
certain inspecting family it's just in
the front set and it turns out that the
derangement girl has minimal lightning
body minus the number of derangements of
n divided by minus 1 which is exactly
than on be need to get n minus 1
factorial and in the data Frankel
theorem and so so this this fact is
actually slightly not really its first
please by rental pool ransom and in 2007
80,000 some and and different people and
their farm boy some other authors as
well and bitter but this this relies on
some them on some representation theory
and and then and say so it's natural
teeth and try to use the same strategy
with the general T version and instead
you just look at the TD arrangement
graph on R sin can we just calculate the
minimum value and plug it into Hoffman's
bound and the answer is no food because
the minimum value at the derangement
growth then has said it's it still has
some order of magnitude roughly the same
as as as in the T equals Ron case so so
plugging it in we just we just get and
something which is big over minus 1
factorial which isn't what we want
and but I mean the natural thing to an
actual thing to try and after that and
in a sense was and a weighted version of
Hoffman's bound and so one can then what
I mean to say so they're basically
wasted hours of Hoffman's brown which
and which don't look at the eigenvalues
of the HSN c matrix but they they look
iDEN values of others of weighted
adjacency matrix and say let me write
down one such xem wasted unloaded
Hoffman's fountains and which turns out
to be sufficient for us and this is Del
sots generalization of the hoffman found
so um this just says that if g is a
number sets go
and a is a cedar adjacency matrix
for the graph G and the eigenvalues say
under 11 m to put the songs around it
end
and with them
and the R value corresponding to the
Cranston back to being a lambda constant
than an independent set
so let's praise this bound so as of us
isn't most of minus lambda n bevel under
constant minus lambda n times on the
reverse seat of the girl and so in order
to yeah yeah i'm just going to write
that down and yeah so a cedar adjacency
matrix and it's just a symmetric matrix
and which has zero entries on the non
edges and any any number you like and on
the edges and which has them Neil ones
Specter is an item dr. so yeah i'll just
write that down t is a see the adjacency
matrix foss4g
FM is symmetric this enters a zero on
all the knowledge and all the very sums
the constant
okay and that's just equipment saying
that the whole ones bachelor's nitin but
that by going back to the natures okay
and so this surprises if a potential and
push strategy for repeating the days of
frank conjecture and in principle we
just have to construct the CD adjacency
matrix with the right a minute or
whether I prophecies and so what
properties will we need the key idea is
that a constant
Trey sort of constant the lender
constants not necessarily number one and
no it isn't but I'm not show you but in
our case actually is so so we could
think of lambda 1 has been land of
constant it's like it's not necessary
yeah and so so the so our goal was to UM
construct them and matrix hey and grow
some crimes in black spray SN and such
that lambda constant is once a brine
analyzing and the minimum writing value
lambda min is minus 1 over teeth falling
factorial of n minus 1 and and obviously
X Y is zero whenever X intercepts why I
suppose at least t that's just a saying
that the presentation that's another
permutation Jackson boy and agree on at
least two points and maybe I'll write
that properly and
I may be re-used great glasses instead
and of course I has to be so not sure
okay and so this again would be enough
to prove the boys front and Joshua but I
mean we don't really know how to analyze
them the art invaluable and see the
adjacency matrices for us on and off it
and for the TD arrangement graph on our
son and I mean SN and is a pretty big
set and the problems put a house has
quite a heightened proxy and so and also
um and also get somewhere and unless Lee
and what we do is we were strict to a
nice class of cedar adjacency matrices
and we look at linear combinations of
paragraphs and generated by conjugacy
classes of limitations with lesson
tifa's points say well the adjacency
matrix if of the ordinary one
derangement graph is just the Khalia
Graaff generator by the derangements and
on the derangements are a union of
conjugacy classes and this means that
the eigenvalues of the derangement graph
a very nice to analyze and we can with
an appeal to classical result of
dorkiness Nahanni and which basically
says that if you have a paragraph on a
front group and which is generated by a
union of chron SE classes of a grid and
then then it's logan spaces when one to
one correspondence with the og's works
and
degree and and also there's a there's an
explicit formula fit for all the eigen
values in terms of the characters of the
og schools and so if if instead of
adjacency matrices or paragraphs we just
take and linear combinations of
adjacency matrices of paragraphs again
generated by unions or chronically
classes and then we get there that then
we can just use the dark onus your honey
results see analyze the eigenvalues of
the CDOs agency make sure as we get and
say maybe i'll just write down there the
dark a nice shot oh honey they're so um
that's like gonna be a finite group
finally and let them or be a complete
set of irreducible representations jeep
now xn the union of Congo see crosses g
and and as for a be the adjacency matrix
of the chi de Graaff generator for x
then the eigenvalues they precisely
these numbers given by this corner and
so for f irreducible representation ray
and the other so i can buy the land
array which is right to a very high to
Sigma
so um yeah rageous ranges over all the
irreducible representations in the
complete set our and so this gives a
complete and description of of all the
young bodies and so do is that so so
this is instructive he is and and we end
up having to you and use some
representation theoretical limits and in
order to guarantee that we can get me
eigen values that we want and this is
where we use the cross for
representation theory are seven and say
there's a very nice description of the
edges for up sensations of this much
repeat and doesn't explicit one-to-one
correspondence between them and the
so-called young tay blaze and so young
table and the partition is just a
diagram youthful left justified boxes
where the the earth ray of the year of
the diagram corresponds to the size of
the earth part of the partition and say
so this this example is the young
diagram corresponding to the partition
5321 and that's a partition of 11 and
that's how we write that something is a
partition or something else and and so
for every friendly partition of what
event and we have energies for
representation of a son and called the
sure module and
and the character of this representation
is very well understood and and and also
the dimension of the the corresponding
edges for representation and can be
calculated explicitly and and the key
thing is this and that if we look at
some factor if we look at it makes these
where the entries and bound is by some
absolute constant over n factorial say
and then the the open Valley is
corresponding to high dimensional
representations automatically very very
small in absolute very very small indeed
and this is kind of similar to a trick
em used by Sonic and zoo and
independently by ghosts and they
basically observed that and if you have
a finite simple group and and the the
smallest non-trivial irreducible
representation of the group is very
large and dimension and then an eigen
value than a bikini growth and sent a
sensor has to have multiplicity at least
the dimension of the irreducible and it
can't actually be very very large and so
we actually use a stronger version of
this because we're dealing with normal
Kaylea gross and we can strengthen the
bound quite a lot but and but anyway the
idea is that but basically the the these
disparate imitations of a fairly high
dimension and what of course upon the
item bodies are very very small provided
we have some bound in this condition on
the matrix and and then and so this this
basically means that we can just deal
with low dimensional irreducible zuv our
son and and just just deal with those
own bodies
and the nice thing is that there are
only an abandoned number depending on T
alone or flow dimension or is used for
excitation of the smush a group and they
correspond to young diagrams and either
with first row of length at least n
minus T or with first quantum of length
of least n minus T and so somehow
because we're only about a number of
them depending on T and we can we can
fix or we can fix the eigenvalues and
cuando is irreducible course one by one
and in a very sort of crude way and then
I'm provided the right at the M the
numbers and the matrix don't get too
large and all the other eigenvalues will
just be okay and so in order to fix
those eigen bodies in fact what we do is
we we track with we translate from the
language of irreducible representations
to the language of permutation
representations because then makes is
involved a lot cleaner but there's
basically and there are basically nice
invertible mappings between and
permutation representations and
nourishes for representation state so
you are so this this all works fine and
and and so this is this is basically the
idea and so then what one problem with
this approach and is that the bounds
that we use on the dimensions and mean
mean that this only works for and very
very large depending on T and and in
fact the days of Frankel conjecture
should be true and for n bigger than to
T and say all right so let me write that
down perhaps
and well so we have these equations and
basically and we we want that the
eigenvalues to have these values on on
the low dimensional reducible
representations and this gives us some
algebraic equations to satisfy right and
with what we do all you have to do is
just temp choose values and two or
values or values of away thing to place
on each and on each conjugacy class of
permutations with less than T fix points
right well we just we just have some
matrix equations the size of a weed or
all you have to check is that they are
invertible and they turn out to be
invertible because of this nice
correspondence between the presentation
representations and the irreducible
representations I haven't really got
time to to give a full sketch of the
free for me now I've only got well two
more minutes really no but and but and
but I can talk to you after as if you
like and so I won't mention some open
problems now and in this area so I'm
first of all this is them for this
general conjecture and on 10 second
funds of permutations
it should be true that we can that we
can say exactly what the maximum
possible size of a 10-second family of
connotations is for every NT and though
these very natural funders of
permutations and and one of these should
win and so these permutations are just
that these fans of conversations are
just and fractional all permutations
sorts that Sigma has at least t plus I
fixed points when the number is one up
to t plus two x
so this is an analog of the famous
Franco conjecture on teens searching
subsets of current such an and and this
the fact conduction is Priya famously
browse waiting for caption in 1907 using
construction techniques and some Club
accounting arguments and complementation
and but it seems like em are inviting
methods can't possibly do something like
this and I know at least these families
have a pretty complicated representation
theory in general for general I and and
say I say and we think that new mothers
would be required to do this another
conjecture is what happens if you weaken
the hypotheses are being TN searching
and you don't demand that the family is
is T intersecting exactly Aegis and
demand that there's no instruction of
size exactly t minus 1 and sorry your
brand new balance suctions of sizes like
your team on this one so yeah so let me
just write that down indirect sure this
air the fun is at least some constant
depending on T and there is a family of
power stations such that for any team
permutations in the family oh and they
don't agree on exactly t minus 1 points
then we have the same boundaries in
their days of Frank Walker conjecture
and say that this is open for general
tea and it's true fear for T equals one
and just bribe the days of Frankel
theorem it's also true for T equals T
and that's a that's a recent resorts and
by me and this this uses them an eigen
body proof to prove an approximate
result and and then Robert crumbly to
stability analysis to deduce an exact
result from the approximate results and
but forty three and four and and
anything anything more and I can write
your techniques don't seem to work at
all so yeah that's slightly annoying and
it would be nice to prove this i'm i'm
pretty sure it's true and faulty and so
it's just better write that down and
Mike Jackson this year and I guess
that's probably good place to stop
sure oh yes okay so i should have i
should mention that this this is a
permutation analog and over conjunction
with others and which is P by Franklin
few ready and so maybe i'll just write
it down and they paid that what's
different this congestion the main
series and in the main in a data phone
call conjecture and we just had we have
a hypothesis that any cheaper mutations
agree on at least t points right or no
it's different as you in trouble here
all this will be then running position
here okay so it's quite a bit from a
little bit and fit BF sir if i have
questions are very good one so young if
this is a conjecture or syllables well
yeah it's a condition conjecture and
it's only a turn for t equals 2 and T
equals one and you doing a little funky
weasel so is the analog of funky weasel
all right I don't think one is mine okay
sounds good question and
for be something in the middle of it so
this isn't this isn't perhaps the one
known as it might be Franklin Freddie
prefer areas of funny of k-on sub sites
with their name suction Assize exactly t
minus one then well provided and pays at
least two T and and and sufficiently
large size varies a nice m ost cheese
pie minus T number of elements subsets
contain the first two elements so yeah
so yeah that's nice and yeah like I say
the same should be shift rotations but
can't interfere in the case of a 1
intersection is the simplest case is it
possible to recover the form of the
optimal solution that saturates the
bound few respectfully like looking for
an hour at the smallest eigen vector or
something like that just like 4 12 a
second shop one interesting to me you
have Alex description of permutations
that saturated the bound right yeah as
possible to get the form of the optimal
solutions p respectfully just very pure
spectral methods and yeah yeah so I
actually mention that and it's I mean
you can't just use a spectral methods
you have to be able to use some kind of
some kind of other arguments as well bit
but yeah there is a spectral proof of
the Equality of the Equality theorem and
it's usually the Equality case but
especially a theorem of cumin and key so
i quote air quality to him yeah so
basically you just you just observe and
one line that if a quality holds then
your coach is the characteristic
function
if of your of your instructing family
must be in the span of the constant
vector and the and the one cosets and
right there that's just one line but
then the difficult thing is to prove
that actually if you have a billion
function which is in the span of the one
cosets then it must be a disjoint union
of one kosis and that's that's actually
a non-trivial result it was so it's
actually a.m. it's actually called it's
actually called the Hungarian matching
algorithm and and it's been rediscovered
every few years brave brave by different
people here in select it's very natural
it's a very natural sort of a statement
in lots of fields per se but yeah I
think I think that I can't exactly
remember and who the first person to
prove it was I seem to remember it was
in the 19th century can you remember our
beer I don't yeah i think it was i think
it was even earlier i think it was
someone in the mighty good job so yes
that's right that's right yeah yeah say
it's over guy he was one of them and yes
a so actually and let's say yeah you're
right there's a probably the nicest
proof of the Equality cases is a
spectral proof but it requires this this
this this lemma which is not not trivial
through and the nicest paper that
probably uses a uses the birkoff 19 and
their animals once customer agencies and
together with linear programming Gioia
see so yeah ok so this conduct or the
left movie you said but they didn't
notice hey do you think it might be over
just with the same similar argument such
as well I don't think about that and I
don't think so and the reason is it and
there isn't really a good analog of love
compressions and put for penetration say
so it's really you can't really get the
proof started and sons and the trouble
is with compression operations for
permutations they can not to preserve
the size of the family so it's a camera
and who were actually able to use some
kind of fixing operation to sit through
that there and with didn't and this
fixing operation doesn't preserve the
size of families but they were able to
prove that in the cases where they were
worried about it did preserve sightsee
and but in general it's it's it's very
parties compressions with permutations
are it seems it's somehow they're very
very much more rigid objects and sets so
yeah yeah and but but it's not it but I
do think that if this is if a proof of
this is this it's probably more of a
connoisseur of resale yeah yeah maybe
some clover estimates and and some more
complicated operations might not do the
trick felony yeah because whenever you
uses a device that makes the soft
unbound for example here in this without
a phone I don't know what with you valid
the hood for the Tigers you get a much
stronger statement because it doesn't
just mount the
sunset about the value of the cemetery
program which relaxes the only answer so
other soldier you're moving am a strong
the result have a meaning in the
community setting or does it tell us
that we can symmetric before you can
move tobacco pollution and its many for
you I know before you yeah I mean
certainly one can get enough stability
information from these companies their
proofs work which is of great interest
to extreme or commerce horas yeah I mean
one last thing about these these I'm
Riley boosters that if the eigen value
is 2k fast enough they show that and
that families wish a fairly large and
have most of their food and must
concentrated on on them on sort of
spaces on the sort of low complexity
spaces somehow and say so this this
enables you to proof silver sea resorts
and I didn't really have time to talk
about sluicey resorts but and but there
is actually a and what well there's
actually an analog of the hilton on
earth in 14 such thing traumas and I
wish I'd done in 2008 as well using
these sort of stability Ottomans say on
so so yeah I mean they did they need to
be a lot a lot of information I Bentley
Ivan actually thought about what other
information they give other than stores
the information and it's good question
and
Logan state of knowledge it's a family
that is also true yeah she is oh well no
maybe there are more nacho sentence you
won't can haunt in the journey and yeah
so quick